two Minnesota women who were confronted
at a public pool for breastfeeding say
they plan to file a discrimination
lawsuit police were called on the women
last week when they refused to cover up
or move to a different location over the
weekend a group of mothers staged a
unique protest outside the pool they
gathered to nurse their children in a
show of solidarity jarika Duncan shows
us how the law might be on the nursing
mom's side jerika good morning good
morning a very might well be good
morning the women and more about 60
miles north of Minneapolis say they were
humiliated at first but the outpouring
of support online and at the so-called
nursing protests encourages their
efforts to advocate for breastfeeding
moms
emotional it is really emotional it's
amazing dozens of Minnesota Moms nurse
their children right outside the Moore
Aquatic Center it's the public pool
where Stephanie Buchanan and Mary Davis
were asked to cover up last week get
such a overwhelming community and state
response from not just moms but dads and
and other family members has been
amazing the women were in the kiddie
pool at the Aquatic Center last
Wednesday with their kids when Buchanan
needed to feed her three-month-old son
Roman a patron came up a lady at the
pool and told me that I needed to cover
up then Davis started breastfeeding her
child in solidarity a pool employee
asked them to cover up or move to the
locker room they refused and decided to
leave the pool shortly after a police
officer approached them I said Minnesota
state law protects me to feed my baby
anywhere that I need to and he said I
understand and I let the establishment
know but they reserve the right to ask
you to leave Minnesota law says a mother
may breastfeed in any location public or
private where the mother and child are
otherwise authorized to be officials
with the city and the Aquatic Center
issued an apology saying while we always
have supported nursing mothers the
situation inside the kiddie pool made
many patrons uncomfortable adding
neither woman was asked to leave I think
it fell short not of our expect us our
expectations but the entire state of
breastfeeding mother's expectations
all 50 states the District of Columbia
Puerto Rico and the Virgin Islands all
have laws that specifically allow women
to breastfeed in any public or private
location another nurse in protest
outside the Aquatic Center is planned
for next month so
it's one of the most natural things in
the world to feed your baby it's just
and I I love that other women are coming
to her support I love that too it
shouldn't be a shameful thing because
it's the right thing to do it's
recommended by doctors and pediatricians
so
and that Roman is so cute I couldn't
take my eyes off of that cute little
baby darika thank you thank you very
much